just months after getting engaged
bachelorette claire crawley and her
winning contestant dale moss have called
it quits
claire will you marry me
yes
a source close to the pair confirms the
news to e.t
explaining quote dale and claire have
ended their relationship
and he broke up with her this past week
i couldn't be
more excited to take this journey with
you i'll see you inside
all right i'll see you soon i tell i
feel like i just met my husband
oh my god dale also confirmed the news
on instagram
tuesday thanking fans for their support
but also noting that their split
is the healthiest decision for both of
us at this time
he also added we only hope the best
things for one another
after we had our first group date in my
mind and in my heart
everything was already written so
everything after the fact just validated
that
and i knew in my heart that it was going
to be her and i at the end of
the end of the day clarendale's roller
coaster romance started last year when
dale was a contestant on claire's season
of the bachelorette
the 32 year old former football player
proved to be claire's early favorite
time and time again i can't wait to see
inside
can't wait either all right thank you
for the great hug will you accept this
road
i will accept this road all right my
first impression was
why are you so perfect i'm not perfect i
feel like you're so
perfect roughly two weeks into filming
dale popped the question to the 39 year
old hairstylist during episode 4
of the hit abc show the record timing
for an engagement was a first for the
bachelorette series
we're engaged oh my god
we're engaged right now yeah there was
also
this moment that went viral what is next
for you guys
moving in together wedding what's up i
think like you know
obviously babies
e.t spoke with bachelor host chris
harrison the month
before the big engagement news was made
public
he reminded fans that the whole goal of
the show was for claire
to find love i'm not mad at claire none
of this
is a bad thing if claire's falling for
somebody and that's where this goes
then great like the whole purpose of
this is to help claire find love
and if we help claire find love great if
i do it in record time that should go on
my record that should be a good
um so that that there shouldn't be a
negative to this
that same month claire opened up to e.t
about her electric connection with her
now
former flame it was one of those things
where
i had never felt it before and i never
even knew what to expect with those
feelings when you have not experienced
it or felt it
you don't know if it exists but when you
feel it
you know exactly what that feeling is
[Music]